We have a voicemail number, which is two one
nine two David P at the top of the show today, we
covered the Dan Crenshaw interview with Joe Rogan.
I got tons of messages and voicemails about it.
Here's one that's asking about sort of like
what's going on with Dan. Take a listen.
Hey, David, this is happening.
That's been show on Joe Rogan
last week. Is he just stupid or is he just pulling
this to continue the tirade? Conservative logic on
how taxes and society support. I think he
is just as dumb as Mouse and Cawthorn and
Lauren Bobert and the like, where all the
intellectual conservatives in the government.
So my I address this a little bit in the first
segment. I think that Dan Crenshaw knows he's
blessing. I don't from everything I know about Dan
Crunchier, he's smart enough and informed enough
to know that the things he said to Joe Rogan a
couple of days ago and the things he said on Fox
News last night about what is fascism and Medicaid
and, you know, immigration. I think he knows that
it's B.S., but he he correctly believes the
average Trump will believe it. If your position
is that. No, Dan Crenshaw really is ignorant,
let me know. But my best assessment right now,
and it can be difficult to tell sometimes, is that
Crenshaw is gaslighting, not Crenshaw is stupid.
We have a bonus show today on which we
will be discussing the push for a fourth
coronavirus stimulus check. There is a push for
this. We will talk about it. We will also talk
about a Utah law that requires biological fathers
to pay half of pregnancy related medical costs,
period, regardless of anything else. And
lastly, Jeff Bezos has come out in support
of a higher corporate tax rate, which Joe Biden
is now pushing. My question is, if you deduct
your taxable income down to zero, does it matter
what the corporate tax rate is? In other words,
if Amazon is paying 21 percent of zero or 28
percent of zero or thirty five percent of zero,
why the hell does Amazon care what the
corporate tax rate is? I think that there's a
propagandistic element to this, which we will
talk about on today's bonus show, get instant
access to the bonus show simply by signing
up at Join Patman dot com. I'll see you that.